حسنًا ، بشكل عام ، يكون الأمر مثيرًا للاشمئزاز عندما
القادة السابقين لدول مهمة من
تعمل القيم الأوروبية من أجل
روسيا التي تحارب هذه القيم
تنشيط مختلف المبعوثين بأطروحات حول
ما الذي يبدو أن الدولة الإرهابية تريده
المفاوضات إذا كانت روسيا حقيقية حقًا
أرادت نهاية الحرب ، لكنها لم ترغب
جمعت الآن الاحتياطيات في أوكرانيا
الجنوب ولن يتكاثروا في الأوكرانية
أراضي المقابر الجماعية للأبرياء المقتولين
الناس لذلك ، من الضروري القتال وهو ضروري
من الضروري ضرب الإرهابيين على أرضنا
لنشر المعلومات عن الأوكرانية
المصالح وتحقيق النجاح لأوكرانيا
انتصارات لكل واحد
إلى مستواه والأوكرانيين وشركائه
لا يمكن وقف الإرهاب إلا معًا
قوة لا تقهر